today on the matt walsh show republicans
have the chance to flip the supreme
court
rescue it from the clutches of left-wing
radical activist judges and potentially
save millions of unborn lives in the
process but some
so-called conservatives are arguing that
it would be unprincipled for republicans
to take advantage of that opportunity
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including chris cuomo giving a
constitution lesson to don lemon on cnn
last night that's how bad it's gotten
and in our daily cancellation i will
finally cancel the entire country of
japan
it's all the entire country is canceled
we'll do that um
at the end of the show of course first i
want to tell you about policy genius you
know
you're not going to be around forever
none of us will and that's why
i know for me i consider it my
responsibility to take care of my family
and those i love that's why
i need life insurance and so do you
september is national life insurance
awareness month
which is great but with everything going
on right now a lot of people aren't even
aware if it's possible don't even know
that it's possible to buy life insurance
at all
good news is that you can and it's still
easy to shop for life insurance right
now
and if you have loved ones depending on
your income you probably should right
now you could save fifteen hundred
dollars or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
can last for a decade or more
those savings really start to add up so
you're saving a lot of money in the long
run
even the short run you're saving a lot
of money as well palsy genius is an
insurance marketplace
built and backed by a team of industry
experts here's how it works step one
you head to policygenius.com in minutes
you can work out how much coverage you
need
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price step two
you apply for your lowest price step
three well that's really it policy
genius will handle all the paperwork and
red tape there's really only two steps
for you and they're very easy
it's definitely been my experience with
policy genius very easy to do you can
navigate your way through it with ease
and i love how policy genius does all
the hard work for me so uh
it's really as simple as that if you
need life insurance head to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could save 1500 or more a
year
by comparing quotes on their marketplace
uh
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it
right one other note um before we
get going today please remember in a few
days all of my content all of my shows
will be on my personal channel not here
on daily wires youtube channel if you're
watching this on youtube right now okay
if you're listening to the you know you
can still get it on on itunes and many
other places but
if you're watching on youtube you have
to go to youtube.com matt walsh
and subscribe to my channel so do that
after the show youtube.com okay
now i have never much like the phrase
establishment conservative
um establishment brings to mind
something like an actual cabal
or cartel of republicans meeting in
secret smoky rooms hatching dastardly
plans
i think the actual reality of the
establishment conservative so-called
does not involve cabals or secret rooms
certainly not smoky
secret rooms there's less of a
conspiracy and more of a
of a mutual instinct to shrink away from
serious ideological fights and to
protect one's reputation
by acting and speaking in a way that
will not offend the sorts of people
that these sorts of people want to be
admired by
all of that said i will i will use
establishment conservatives today just
just for lack of a better term
may not be the best description but it
is succinct at any rate so we'll use it
and so i can report that establishment
conservatives seem to
finally be getting on the same page in
the in the wake of justice ginsburg's
death
they they've tried desperately to think
of a way to take these winning cards
we've been dealt and lose the hand
anyway
and that's what they're very good at
doing they all it seems have come up
with the same plan
so here's jonah goldberg in the la times
i'll read a little bit of this he says
towards the end of his piece
he says what some now dismiss as
politics and posturing are actually
important considerations
that honor the conservative distinction
between can and should and fall under
such
antiquated notions as statesmanship
prudence legitimacy
consistency and precedent these concepts
put maintaining the long-term health of
our institutions
above the demands of the moment take
senator lindsey graham who promised in
2016 that if
an opening were to come up in the last
year of president trump's term
a nominee would not be considered until
after the election by going back on that
promise in such spectacular fashion
he's not merely debasing himself he's
also teaching people
that nothing politicians say matters by
the way is there
is there anyone over the age of 12 who
needs to be taught that lesson
really even politicians will lie i had
no idea
scandalized anyway he continues moreover
merely on the level of real politic
abandoning all considerations other than
what you can get away with amounts to
preempted
preemptive disarmament for the wars to
come the pernicious logic of apocalyptic
politics
works on the assumption that the long
term doesn't matter but the long term
always becomes now eventually
this is why the senate could use some
posturing in politics right now
republicans have the ability to replace
ginsburg before the election or
immediately after an lame duck session
that is a huge bargaining chip and given
that the gop's majority is so slim
it's a chip that can be traded even by
even a handful of republican senators
so here's the deal that he proposes a
few republicans could agree to postpone
the process
until after the election in exchange for
a few democrats agreeing
never to vote for a court-packing scheme
this would give voters some buy-in for
whatever happens next
okay um did you get that
the plan here is for republicans to
choose not to vote on a justice
as long as democrats pinky promise
really pinky promise okay like super
serious
to never pack the court in the future
david french
in time agrees he says what can be done
an increasing number of center-right
legal scholars including the american
enterprise institute's adam white
and george mason law school uh professor
ilya
sohman are proposing a variant of an
approach
best summed up as make them keep their
word it goes something like this
first trump makes his pick second the
state the senate applies the schumer
principle and gives the nominee a
hearing
this will have the benefit of giving the
american people a more complete picture
of the qualifications and philosophy of
the nominee
and thus the stakes of the presidential
election third then
the senate then applies the graham rubio
cruz rule
and does not vote before the election if
trump wins
they then vote on the nominee now
there have been other articles in reason
uh the bulwark
others have echoed this same plan
republican republicans declined to
confirm a nominee
which you know confirming it would
potentially flip the court in favor of
constitutionalism
in the process save millions of lives
declined to do that in return the
democrats promise with all their heart
and souls to never pack the court
now the problems with this plan are i
think obvious but let's discuss them
anyway
first of all we should emphasize this
again
there is absolutely no reason whatsoever
to
not confirm trump's picks okay this is
not even a problem that we need to be
thinking about
there is nothing whatsoever strange or
outrageous or controversial about a duly
elected president putting forth a
judicial nominee
and duly elected senators confirming or
not confirming that nominee
this is what they were elected to do
there is no reason not to do it
french and goldberg and the others they
go on and on about how about principle
and how
somehow in some way it violates
principle
for the president and the senate to
perform their constitutional duties
this is nonsense it is abject nonsense
the only thing it potentially violates
is what some of them
said in 2016. well so what who cares
some republicans made a bad argument for
not holding a vote for garland
they said that you know they shouldn't
do it because there's an election coming
up
that was a bad argument that was a dumb
argument they should have said
they aren't going to vote because they
refuse to allow another activist on the
court
and they have the constitutional
authority to prevent it and so they will
and they also and they could have
pointed out they also have the mandate
from their constituents
demanding that they prevent it that's
what they should have said
instead they made a bad stupid argument
are they now
because of principle required to live by
that bad argument forever
if you do the right thing but you
justify it with faulty reasoning are you
now required to live by that faulty
reasoning for the rest of your natural
life
if i save a kitten from getting run over
and someone asks me why i saved it and i
say
well because it's tuesday does that mean
that from then on i must allow kittens
to be run over on wednesday and thursday
or should i just continue saving the
kittens even if my initial reasoning for
doing it
must be adjusted or abandoned now that
was a weird analogy granted but i think
it works
even if it doesn't work it just
demonstrates my point about faulty
reasoning
um second point we cannot make a deal
like this
with democrats because it relies on
democrats keeping their word
not just their word but future democrat
politicians
have to honor the word of previous ones
the thing is i wouldn't trust democrats
to honor their word period
but i wouldn't even expect them to honor
the word of some other democrats from
years ago
i couldn't even blame them for breaking
that word
i just i can't believe that men like
french and goldberg really think that a
plan like this is feasible or plausible
or coherent
it's like if a guy has taken 10 hostages
and he's demanding 10 million dollars in
a plane ride out of the country
so you give him the 10 million dollars
and the plane and you tell him to take
the hostages with him
but when he gets wherever he's going he
has to promise to let them go
yeah that's not a deal that's not
negotiation that's not a compromise
that's just simply giving the other side
everything they could ever want
and in this case it would be like doing
it when the hostage taker has
no gun and no bomb you have all the ammo
you hold all the cards they can't even
and yet you still give them everything
you want
this is what passes for principle among
some on the right
it is so weak and limp and pathetic that
i can almost feel my testosterone levels
dropping
as i read some of these pieces now
here's what we must understand about
democrats okay
they say that conservatives are racist
fascist nazis in league with the klan
and they say that uh that
you know conservatives want to control
women and remove their autonomy and
enslave them like the handmaid's tale
and the thing is they really believe it
or at least they act as if they do and
what that means is that they're going to
do
everything in their power and tell any
lie they need to tell
in order to in order to stop those
oppressive woman enslaving neo-nazi
savages
that's why the you know the kavanaugh
hearings went the way they did
they they could act to destroy this man
destroy his family slander him to fame
him ruin him
and they could feel entirely justified
and noble every step of the way after
all
they're up against nazis remember
wouldn't you accuse a nazi of gang rape
if that's what you needed to do in order
to stop
stop him from seizing power of course
the difference is that republicans
aren't actually nazis so that's all a
bunch of historic
hysterical bull on the other hand
democrats are actually infanticidal
radicals
who believe that it's morally acceptable
to dismember a fully developed infant
and throw the pieces into a dumpster
that is the truth they really believe
that that is their real life
position and they want a court that
reflects it and shares it and advances
it
what that means is that the ruthlessness
they show when it comes to the supreme
court or anything else
is not morally justified because the
basis for it is false
and their actual objectives are evil but
for republicans it is morally justified
to do whatever must be done within the
bounds of the law to stop them
the basis for our actions is not false
it is really true
that is what we're up against and you
are not a principled conservative unless
you are willing to look into that
darkness
confront it acknowledge it and fight it
with all you have
let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i'm a big believer in in
reading i think it's really important to
read books to set aside time to read to
learn
you know uh that's been my point about
about
you know things like going to college
and and the thing is whether you go to
college or not
whatever you do for for your education
if you don't continue
learning every day of your life even
after you graduate
then you know a few years after college
you're
you're going to be just as dumb as
anybody else uh
learning is something that has to happen
every single day we have to continue to
learn
if you get out of school no matter how
much time you spend in school if you get
out and
then just stop learning from then on
it's it was all a waste of time because
you're going to forget everything you're
not going to retain
has to be a continual process the
problem is finding time to learn
and that's where our latest sponsor
thinker comes in
you know our fast-paced world is tough
to make to make reading a priority at
least it used to be
now with thinkor.org they summarize the
key ideas from new and
noteworthy nonfiction giving you access
to an entire library of great books in
bite-sized form
you can read or listen to hundreds of
titles in a matter of minutes
they've got old classics they've got
recent bestsellers they've got a huge
library of books
that you can go and check out um and
these are you know if you don't have the
time to read the entire book
you can just you can go and you can get
the the basic insights i've been using
thinker for a long time
and um i i love it i think it's great
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across many categories
from current affairs to politics
business education history relationships
um you'll even find titles from a guy
named matt walsh the unholy trinity is
there and
there's ben shapiro's right side of
history is there it doesn't stop there
though there's
tons of titles what i would what i would
recommend is just go to thinkor.org
and check out the titles take a look at
what they have
and you're going to find plenty of stuff
there where you say to yourself well i'd
like to learn about it i don't have time
to read the whole book i'd like to learn
about it though
and you can do that if you want to
challenge your preconception to expand
your horizons become a better thinker
go to thinkor.org that's t h i
t-h-i-n-k-r.org to start a free trial
and download the app today let them know
you heard about them on the matt wall
show
that's thinker.org
okay let's get to our five headlines i
just saw this
come across my desk didn't really come
across my desk i just like to phrase it
that way
uh that mitt romney has announced that
he will
vote that that uh that he's in favor of
of
voting on a nominee before the election
i guess there are people who are
surprised by that they thought that you
know would would romney be one of the
the squishes who said we should wait
till after the election
i'm not surprised by it at all actually
uh because you have to understand
mitt romney is a senator from utah he
represents utah
and uh if you know anything about utah
the voters in utah
extremely socially conservative they
were they're not gonna tolerate the guy
who represents them
standing in the way of potentially
flipping the court in favor of pro-life
you know and conservatism that was just
not going to happen so romney really has
no choice
which is a credit to the voters in utah
um
but we still have a long way to go
because
right now the votes are lined up but
democrats have
barely even begun to launch their
assault on
uh trump's nominee who hasn't even been
officially named yet
and so we'll see right now they've got
whatever 53 votes
we'll see if all those republicans um
hold the line i i think romney will no
matter what
because like i said i don't think he has
a choice his his his
base his voters in utah won't tolerate
other other senators like
susan collins we'll see okay just to
give you an idea
we move on to number one here just to
give you an idea of how bad the bias is
in media
here's a conversation between don lemon
and chris cuomo last night where cuomo
is the sane and rational one in the
dialogue
listen if the democrats were in control
of the senate right now
and trump was president and he wanted to
nominate a justice what do you think
they'd say
well i think they do the same thing they
did in 2016 they'd they'd do it
that's what they did that's my point
that's why nobody cares what the
democrats are saying
no no no no i think they do exactly what
they did in 2016. you can say what you
want about democrats
democrats usually wet the bid they're
not as strategic
give trump after what happened with
merrick garland i think
if yes i think they'd abide by
well it's different because it's
different because democrats did not make
the promise so you keep comparing things
that aren't equal
democrats did not make the same promise
in 2016
democrats were on the other side they
said it wasn't a problem because it was
a bs all right
to explain what they were doing
semantics they didn't allow
the the his nominee to go through they
wouldn't even have a hearing they said
we're not going to do it
so that wasn't democrats doing that that
was republicans doing it
and if you come on this side i don't
know what democrats were doing there
would not mean that they were being
hypocritical if they did it okay so you
see yeah he
the dude really claimed there that
democrats if they were in control would
allow trump's nominee to go through
they they would cooperate with trump and
play fair lemon says that's
that's that's what we're getting so
we're just we're just pretending that
that they didn't try to stop a trump
nominee by accusing him of serial gang
rape by the way
republicans stopped an obama nominee by
not holding a vote
which is an authority and power they had
legally democrats stopped or tried to
stop
a republican nominee by orchestrating a
smear campaign and accusing him of being
a
the ringleader of a gang of teenage
rapists okay
one of those methods is an assault on
the rule of law
and norms and decency the other is not
and uh you know i'll let you guess which
is which later in the same conversation
to make matters worse cuomo
had to explain the constitution to don
lemon he
cuomo had to become the constitutional
scholar in the conversation watch
no matter what happens everybody's
thinking we're gonna have to blow up the
entire system
and you know what we're gonna have to do
i don't know you know what we're gonna
yes we have to do you just gotta
honestly from what your closing argument
is you have to get rid of the electoral
college
because the people i don't see it
because the minority in this country
decides who the judges are and they
decide who the president is
they need a constitutional amendment to
do that and if democrats if joe biden
wins
democrats can stack the courts and they
can do that amendment and they can get
it passed well
two thirds vote in the congress and
three quarters of the state legislature
they may be able to do that maybe
yeah it's pretty clear from that
conversation there that don lemon really
thought
that just by taking what if if if
democrats had just a simple majority in
the senate they could amend the
constitution that's all it would require
uh a profoundly stupid individual is don
lemon
um and also a partisan dishonest hack on
top of it that's that's a that's tough
break
when you're you know stupid as well as
incredibly dishonest
which is why for me it's like i that's
why i figure i know i'm stupid so i
might as well try to be honest like i
got to have something going for me at
least
let's go to number two uh alan degeneres
was back on the air yesterday in her
opening monologue she addressed
all of the accusations that have been
circling
around out there that she's a monstrous
sociopath who mistreats everybody around
her
and here she is addressing it as you may
have heard
this summer there were allegations of a
toxic work environment at our show
and then there was an investigation i
learned that things happened here that
never should have happened i take that
very seriously and i want to say i am so
sorry to the people who are affected
i know that i'm in a position of
privilege and power and i realize that
with that comes responsibility and i
take responsibility for what happens at
my show
this is the ellen degeneres show i am
ellen degeneres
my name is there my name is there my
name is
on underwear
[Laughter]
we have had a lot of conversations over
the last few weeks about the show
our workplace and what we want for the
future we have made the necessary
changes and today
we are starting a new chapter
yeah i have to say less than inspiring
um i i you know i felt like
she was just taking whatever bs spiel
she gave to the staff
during the staff meeting you know when
they first got together and
repeating it here also the whole idea
that she found out
about bad things that happened is
obviously bogus because the whole
controversy and scandal was that
she was the one doing the bad thing so
she's claiming that she she found out
about the things that she herself was
allegedly doing
now you could always say of course that
you don't believe all these stories
about ellen degeneres and
um i fully agree that false accusations
do happen but there is a certain point
right
where you know i mean dozens of people
who
who have worked with you and have been
around you
are all saying the same things about you
and telling the same kinds of stories
there's a point where there's no
plausible reason to disbelieve it
and then what's also conspicuous is that
all these people coming out some on the
record some off the record saying el
degeneres is just an absolute sociopath
and it's horrible to everybody and all
of that like you can't even look her in
the eyes when she walks down the hallway
that kind of thing
there's really there was really nobody
very very few people coming out in
defense of her and saying no you know
what this is crazy she's a wonderful
person
very few people saying that and that's
that really you know that's that's an
indication that there's an issue when
everyone who's ever been around you
agrees that you're a scumbag and almost
no one who's been around you will say
otherwise
yeah you know i think probably we can
draw some conclusions at that point
number three from the daily wire
says nba superstar lebron james claims
that the votes of black people do not
matter in america
noting that he's seen recounts and a
parent suggesting that black votes have
been intentionally voided in his
lifetime
james said black people in the community
don't believe that their vote matters
and he was explaining why he was
apathetic about voting when he was
younger we grow up and don't think that
our vote actually matters it doesn't
we've seen recounts before we've seen
our voices be muted our whole lives
and then he goes on from there yes uh
lebron james
superstar mega celebrity i mean
everything he says is headline news
but his voice is being muted lebron
james's voice is being muted let me
let me just ask lebron at this point um
maybe you could just tell us lebron
how much attention do you need the whole
world
to pay to you before you will agree
that you're not being oppressed like how
much
is needed because right now do you need
i guess my question is do you actually
need everyone in the world
to to do nothing with their lives but
listen to you
and talk about you is that what you
require in order to not be oppressed
anymore
because apparently being a
multi-millionaire mega super
famous celebrity that's not enough so
just just let me know what you what you
need
do you need all of the fame and all of
the money in the entire world
in order to because if so just let us
know lebron because the world is here
for you
that's that's why we all exist is simply
for you and so all you have to do is let
us know what you need
and we'll be here for you yeah i mean
nothing nothing irresponsible or
reckless about that right though by the
way the
a you know lebron james claiming that
black people's votes are being discarded
or thrown out or what
no basis for that whatsoever he's just
making that up
so he says that he goes out saying that
we're being hunted in the street no
basis for that either
but all of the uh all of the the
requisite
uh chaos and anarchy and everything that
that comes
from false narratives like this lebron's
not
susceptible to any of that he's he's
protected from that behind his
his gated house in his mansion so he
doesn't care
great guy that lebron james number four
aoc alexandra quezada cortez has a
message that
um i actually agree with this may be the
first thing she's ever said that i agree
with listen
i'm sorry to tell you you're not going
back to brunch we're not going back to
brunch
that's not happening i have to say i
could not agree more um i don't think
anybody should be going to brunch i
agree with her brunches for cowards
who don't want to step up and choose
between lunch or breakfast
i've always said that you know it's no
wonder that women brunch is very popular
with women what does that tell you
because women are notorious
for for being totally unable to make
food-related decisions and so
they invented this brunch thing because
they can't even decide what meal they
want to have
if you're having brunch then that means
it's a time you know it's what brunch is
going to be 10 10 o'clock 11 o'clock
so that's a time when you cut you could
either be having a late
breakfast or an early lunch and i think
it's up for you to have some conviction
and decide
and fyi if you have to choose between
lunch and breakfast always choose
breakfast i think that
i think i i i think we can all agree on
that number five the emmys
happened on sunday hosted by jimmy
kimmel um i didn't watch the show
uh i i was gonna watch it but then
somebody offered to come to my house
and stab me in the jaw with a rusty
screwdriver instead and i just thought
that was a much more appealing way to
spend
my time and it just so happens that
there's no shortage of people who would
be willing to stab me in the jaw with a
rusty
screwdriver so it kind of works out so i
didn't watch it but i did
uh there was one segment from the show
that caught my eye after the fact
as it's been making the rounds online
this is a i guess supposed to be a
comedy bit between
host jimmy kimmel and actor anthony
anderson but the cringe factor here
is off the charts watch before we
announce the nominees you know i have a
few things that uh
i'd like to say you do yes i do because
in rehearsal i thought we decided that
we're just you know we have a record
number of black emmy nominees this year
which is great this is the part where
the white people
start to applaud oh
and nod oh thank you jimmy
all right these emmys would have been
all star
these emmys would have been nba all-star
weekend and wakanda
all wrapped into one this was supposed
to be the blackest
emmys ever y'all wouldn't have been able
to handle how black it was going to be
but because of kovitt we can't even get
in the damn building
this isn't what it should have been
jimmy but but you know what
i'm still rooting for everybody black
because black stories
black performances and black lives
matter
say it with me jimmy black lives matter
louder jimmy black lives matter
louder jimmy say it so that my pens can
hear
it black lives matter that's right
and because black lives matter black
people will stay at home tonight
to be safe which is fine because guess
what
y'all don't know how to light us anyway
no jimmy i i'm glad i got that off i am
i am too yeah i'm glad you did i'm i'm
i'm appreciative that you've given me a
safe space to say this from
well it's my pleasure you know that yes
uh could you scoot over so i can stand
on this star
okay yes i will bring out all right yes
that was the most uncomfortable thing
i've ever seen in my life it was it was
it was cringe comedy but not in a good
way cringe comedy minus the comedy just
pure cringe all the way down
what was the comedy supposed to be
exactly this is the ritual humiliation
of a neutered white man
now i admit sort of grotesquely
fascinating to watch in a certain way
but not really funny
now if this wasn't the emmys you know if
this was
we know this isn't the case in the
enemies but if it wasn't the emmys i
might think
that this was supposed to be a parody of
blm and its constant
demands for pledges of allegiance and a
parody of the
pathetic little puppy dogs like kimmel
who bark on command as they're told
but i don't think it it is a parody um i
think it's
it's just exactly what we've been seeing
in fact there was another example of it
uh we've seen these you know mobs of blm
people walking down the
the road and demanding that you know
diners at restaurants put up the
black power fist and all of that here
was another recent example from a few
days ago
um let's let's take a look at this
right now black lives matter say black
lives matter bro
you didn't i didn't hear you okay
hold on let him talk let him talk let
him talk thank you all right
thank you yeah that was in portland i
believe of course and
that dude he got his truck smashed
anyway
apparently he did what he was told and
then he came out and the truck was still
smashed
he performed the choreography danced the
jig jumped through the hoops
and they still went after him anyway
that's the way it goes because that's
the way it always
goes and when i say that's the way it
always goes i mean
i'm talking about going back through
history okay way before blm
this is how evil oppressors always
operate this is one of the hallmarks of
oppressors
is that they demand pledges of
allegiance displays of fealty
whether sincere or not one of the most
common things that tyrants do is that
they
they they need you to at least pretend
they need you to say the words and
perform the actions your pers because
your personal views are irrelevant to
them they don't care about that it's
your submission they want
so blm is following this script and
there's a lot of historical
precedent for it none of it good but
there's a lot of it
on the other hand you know you notice
how you never see gangs of
of pro-lifers at the march for life you
never see them
gathering around uh someone and
demanding
that the person expressed their support
for the pro-life cause that never
happens
because pro-lifers really care about
their professed cause and their
professed causes saving babies
and coerced statements of of of support
from people who are scared of you know
getting their asses kicked by a mob of
angry people
that does nothing to advance the cause
of saving babies
now for blm antifa etc
the real cause is control and coerced
statements of support really do advance
that cause
and they would advance it no matter what
the statement was doesn't even matter
what it is
they might as well demand that you do
the macarena or you know sing shall be
coming around the mountain it doesn't it
doesn't matter what you're doing
or what it is they say oh say black
lives matter put up the fist
that doesn't even make a difference the
whole point is simply to train you
to do what they say and that's it that's
all they want
all right let's get to our um daily
cancellation okay this will be a quick
one today i just need to to cancel japan
real quick just just get in cancel japan
get out i don't think i'll need more
than three minutes to cancel
a whole country um it's it's that easy
jaban
japan today is being canceled for this
we'll play the footage for you there it
is
um now this is a giant robot that
they're building in japan
i'm told this is a life-sized gundam
i have no idea what a gundam is i assume
that's japanese for spectacular waste of
money i don't know
now you can see here all the things this
robot can do and by all the things i
mean
it can it can give a thumbs up it can
move its arms
it can kneel even giant robots pander to
black lives matter apparently
but but that's all it can do it can't
fly it can't shoot lasers it can't do
anything else
now i ask you what the hell function
will a giant 60-foot robot that gives a
thumbs-up
serve well i'll tell you what the
function is it serves a function of
japan being able to say to the world hey
guys look at this thing that we did
and the world goes oh cool and that's it
that's the whole purpose
think of how many man hours went into
this how many people worked on it there
are people who spent years
going to work to build this okay honey
i'm off to work to buy
to build the giant robot today all right
hey by the way has anyone explained to
you why
you're doing that uh no i guess not they
haven't explained it i have no idea
now people online are saying that japan
is going to take over the world with its
giant robots
they're saying that we should be shaking
in our tiny boots as we behold the
future of warfare
no do you realize how utterly useless
this hunk of metal
would be in the context of modern
warfare first of all
you could easily knock it over with a
missile from a fighter jet that would be
it probably a strong wind would do
it and then it will crash down and crush
whatever happens to be underneath it
speaking of crushing things where would
you use this robot
you couldn't use it to defend your own
cities because you just end up
destroying as many buildings as you save
which if you recall was a major problem
in power rangers are you going to try to
launch some sort of foreign invasion
with these things
the enemy would see you coming literally
from a mile away
lumbering along at the you know the
speed of two miles an hour in your giant
tin cans a few missiles later and all of
your robots are splayed out on the
ground
like really expensive dominoes you know
where this would come in handy
if you were say laying siege to a
fortress in medieval europe i could see
it being useful in that setting
but unfortunately japan is about 600
years too late for that
it would also be useful in the star wars
universe where the technology to make
fully conscious robots
is so ubiquitous that every hobo in the
galaxy has five of them a piece
and everyone flies around in spaceships
that can exceed the speed of light
like it's nothing and yet the most
advanced weapon is a laser sword
you know that you need to be within two
feet of
the enemy to use so in that sort of
reality where technology is somehow a
million years ahead of us
and 700 years behind us at the same time
i i could see the giant robot filling a
role
but not in this reality the reality we
happen to live in and are stuck with
listen i would love if there was a real
function for giant robots
in this world i would but there isn't
and so for that reason japan
is canceled and i remind you again now
is a good time to go if you're watching
on youtube go to youtube.com
matt walsh and subscribe uh and uh if
you don't of course
you are cancelled as well we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico and our audio is
mixed by robin fenderson
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
while democrats exploit the death of
ruth bader ginsburg the late justice
sends
a message on her final wishes from
beyond the grave
then rioters burn down more of our
politics out of love and compassion
and blm deletes its beliefs check it out
on the michael knowles show